hello reject nation I'm Greg Alva I'm
Chevy Kuwait I'm Laura Francesca today
we are sitting in order of most
subscribers to Lee subscribers that's
recent though yeah Lauren will flip and
she'll go up higher and then I'll go to
the bottom it'll be great they'll be
happy for everyone guys so a while ago
jab eco and I we made a guest appearance
and the newly launched web series called
a plan that is ridden and stars lower
and Francesca from Iowa my Lawrence that
was cold Appling yeah a plant it's a web
series the script I got was untitled I
only got lines napkin I think I think
your director just shattered words that
mean to say we haven't seen it yet and
we thought hey this would be fun if
Lauren could introduce us to the episode
we make cameo in and we'll be together
and then we'll probably do a separate
video on Lauren's channel we'll talk
about our awesome unique experience the
crazy trailer we had set up for us
services loss of the RAF's services that
were they delivered food directly to us
so I'm pleased slept on our couches
bagels from Beverly Hills guys and
telling you is off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she made her lunch even though like I'm
not an intern anymore and I kept trying
to explain she doesn't drink coffee and
she comes in Griffin barks orders at us
she knows she was not a responsible pet
no it might be all the time it's quite
annoying right did she hey she kept
calling me changed I think she's a nasty
girl is it at the arcade on a classic
friend always and that is why you were
the backbone of this company Frank
all the time if she didn't dress so sexy
at work this wouldn't have happened can
you slap them on the butt
no can you call them no no I wish so
many we're told that lawsuits were
expensive now all I can do is go home to
LA and rebuild wow setup that's the
setup right there the credits were came
out really well I now know what the show
is about so it actually deals with
certain themes of the way women are
mistreated yes in the industry oh that's
about how guys were mistreated yeah like
just terrorizing men yeah a vendor to
the company card when I read the script
I thought it was about how women are
evil in the app business but apparently
that's not the show at all I get the
setup you crash burn and I have to
rebuild and I take it the rest of the
episodes aren't as like hyper edited
because this is like the set up episode
yeah okay telling people where it's
gonna go
I mean honestly the best parts were me
and him yeah yeah I'm just gonna put
that out there right now I've got a lot
of comments about you guys too really
yeah good it's a very timely video you
know hashtag time's up I like that it's
making fun of it at the same time it's
having fun with it as opposed to just
being straight serious yeah because
we've been kind of beaten over the head
with this message which is great but
it's nice to have something of levity at
the same time that's still expressing
the same message it's like a YouTube
wackier version of Silicon Valley in a
way yeah yeah okay I understand what the
show is now if this show goes anywhere
else could we be can we get a spin-off
series yeah yes two brothers yeah I get
I get to play myself and you get to play
that guys anymore yeah it was fun to
film it was fun to film we'll talk about
that on Laurens Channel though yeah well
thanks for showing us the story you guys
can watch the video in full-screen the
link in the description box for you guys
the whole web series is up on the I want
my Lauren channel and I'm giving away an
autographed photo if you come and
comment on every episode so guys if you
want a picture of them maybe I'll like
take one of them and make them autograph
it too it's a blatant lie I've commented
on every single video of yours I haven't
received a single aw I would never agree
to signing anything
I didn't even sign a contract to do this
video people I got to give someone an
autograph in India and it was in a Dan
Brown book all she had on her at the
time
I gotta get someone an autograph and
they thought I was my brother so they
tore it up and all right guys well you
can subscribe to the real rejects check
out [ __ ] eco ace Channel it's nothing
like mine
Laurens Channel I want my Lauren is on
the youtubes as well check out the whole
web series catch you on the
flippety-flip